today we're trying Canadian taters
potato chips potato chips this was to be
like epic chips I heard there better be
a poutine chip
I want a maple syrup flavored chip let's
do this
Montreal smoked meat fondant who made
the Montreal they're very vague about
what type of me it looks like a roast
beef sandwich
ooh it smells like Arby's yeah it's so
meaty it has a little bit of spiciness
to it my mouth is burning I don't know
what you're talking about
what they've nailed it but I don't like
it you know they can put like Neal than
a kiss
she's like Willy Wonka yeah cowboy
barbecue beans I love barbecue beans
were there Cowboys in Canada this is the
Western Canada finalist which makes a
lot of sense I got so excited they taste
like the syrup that's at the bottom of a
can of beans are you tasting the beans
at all yeah oh I'm into these get me
these in every 7-eleven across America
what does Pei mean private investigator
food Pei is an Edward Island Atlantic
Canada which is like Saskatchewan right
this tastes like some buttery goodness
like some Paula Deen
it literally just tastes like cheddar
and sour cream chips yeah I'm a fan I'm
a supporter of these fire chicken Poulet
Oberg this is from Ontario this is how
you know there are a lot of Indian
people who live in Ontario it kind of
tastes like I'm eating just cumin it
tastes like sauce I think it has a crab
vibe it's the Canadian style of Indian
which is just not spicy at all
I'll put it into those gotta be the big
bean because when else have I tried that
I love that's the best
yeah that's the best because you'll take
these home with you then yeah yeah yeah
I'm an Arctic I'm gonna take the beans
yeah how do you get these in America I'm
gonna drop every other cause I care
about and only work towards getting
these chips in America